salve salve renan inquérito
opa boa noite a todos
eu faço parte da cultura hip hop e uma
música chamada rep
é um estilo de música a equipe chamou
muita atenção na adolescência
sou nascido em 1987
talvez uma das últimas gerações até uma
vida totalmente sem internet
na cultura hip hop esses quatro
elementos
o dj é mais comum a gente costuma ver
eles nas palavras o break
o boy o pickel que dança dança de rua
o grafite às vezes é considerado como
vamos porque confunde o grafite com
piche
mas não tem nada a ver grafite arte é
uma expressão que o ms que é o cara que
faz rimas linha de frente a gente
absorve todas as coisas que acontecem na
sociedade no mundo e tenta colocar isso
em forma de poesia pra ver se a gente
consegue transformar onde a gente pisa
onde a gente vai trazendo sempre alerta
para as comunidades para as pessoas que
não têm voz e eu e meus amigos
costumavam ver a nossa adolescência rap
hardcore era um estilo musical que o que
a gente mais se identificava
eu particularmente gostava mais de rap
porque eu tinha os mesmos ideais
acreditavam nas mesmas coisas e nessa
pracinha que a gente se reunia
naquela época a gente andava de skate
também e essa pracinha foi toda
modificada
ela tinha balança tudo mas a gente
colocou o corrimão caixote transição
todos os obstáculos para a gente poder
se aperfeiçoar fazer as manobras que a
gente gostava
e eu e meus amigos
ouvia bastante funk nas rádios sertanejo
pagode e pra gente joão com outra gente
acaba fazendo paródia e era engraçado
porque pra gente usuário a gente usar a
música é também e acabou voando até uns
cabo bravo depois carro revoltado queria
obrigar um com o outro mas sair nessa
época já conseguiu já percebi que tinha
uma facilidade pra criar eu só vou saber
se expressar não sabe escrever
eu fui um cara bastante problemático na
minha adolescência tem muito problema
para os meus professores até peço
desculpas ea educação que eu acredito eo
hip hop
eles foram que fizeram a na construção
do meu caráter
o hip hop que eu acredito é 100%
educativo e na nossa época como nós não
tinha acesso à internet além de nós
comprar cds no camelô para saber o que
está rolando o cenário musical
a gente buscava revista da rep power hip
hop brasil e trazia muito conhecimento
pra gente nos preparar para o mundo
moderno para nova era e com o passar dos
anos eu acabei indo morar para fora
em brusque fiquei um tempo morando lá e
em 2015 eu retornei para lages onde eu
tinha muito amor é pela cidade então
resolvi retornar em 2015 estava
desempregado e passava o problema não só
financeiro mas eu senti uma angústia
dentro de mim que eu precisava fazer
algo pela comunidade então refletir
sobre os problemas e econômico e as
coisas que estão acontecendo na nação
brasileira é o rumo que estava tomando a
nação de centeio comecei a escrever e
sair os primeiros versos aí tá tudo o
contrário sistema falido gente sem fé em
deus e na escuridão
que vai dar pé político metendo mentira
de desenvolvimento num país onde tem que
fazer greve para ganhar o aumento no
salário digno papel de alimentar os
filhos
eles não têm que fazer os corre puxar o
gatilho governo muda vai ficar por isso
mesmo
só que isso é mais que visto que é o
final dos tempos e eu que achava que o
mandou era só maldade mas hoje eu vejo
várias igrejas pregando falsidade pastor
corrupto para o da ffu hoje é moda e o
povo se conforma ninguém faz nada enrola
da perdendo o brilho sozinho e sem
esperança famílias se divertindo
aplicando só por causa da herança mas
confirma o projeto toda a esperança no
senhor que essa história mude para o meu
próximo raps ao falar de amor e
continuei escrevendo e assim não tinha o
nome dessa música que estava construindo
aí como erick era amante dos games
eu jogava bastante mortal kombat e foi
aonde que surgiu o nome dessa música
quando a gente escolheu o personagem do
mortal kombat tinha um locutor falava
xuxa desta ou seja escolher o seu
destino e virou nome dessa canção desse
primeiro versa escolha o seu destino
então não estava satisfeito com a
realidade local e eu queria dar uma
resposta rápida para isso
foi onde eu criei o projeto amplitude eu
não sabia palestrar não sabia nada eu
queria fazer alguma coisa que interferir
na realidade dos jovens e comecei uma
nas escolas em comunidades carentes e
usava minha experiência de vida eo meu
conhecimento com a convicção que eu
podia mudar onde fosse
e realmente mudou mães de alunos me
procuraram perguntando o que tinha feito
com o filho dela melhorou não só na
escola mas dentro de casa
alunos que tiveram problema em
envolvimento com droga é muito precoce
também procuraram dizia que depois que
eles me ouviram ou viram minhas músicas
eles começaram a levar mais a sério os
estudos
tanto que tem um hoje me com um que ele
vai ver o cantar quando vou cantar algum
barulho algum lugar aqui em lages
ele vai lá eu fico emocionado quando vou
cantar pô eu falei tanta coisa o cara
absorveu está aí a trabalhando estudando
então isso é enriquecedor e sabe quando
rebeldes não dentro de você disse
é aí que as coisas começam a acontecer
eu senti uma certa apreensão porque está
pensando fora da caixa se incomoda massa
disse não mas esse é o caminho
quero ser escritor quero ser um rap e
por que não em um certo dia estava em
casa escrevendo e essa música o nome
dela era o que será que será era como se
eu fosse um jogo cheio de dúvidas
e eu queria voltar 15 anos atrás mas com
a maturidade que tenho hoje imagina 15
anos mais novo mas que a maturidade hoje
nossa fase é um estouro e que hora foi
muito louca essa música porque ela
trouxe bastante significado e acredito
muito nos sinais que a vida nos dá e
todo escritor não deixa passar nada
despercebido e eu vou cantar agora pra
vocês
quero ficar de pé comigo e é
um pouquinho abaixo ei
ainda em sochi ele somente chegou o seu
universo nossa paixão já o lá possui
naturalmente de amanhã seu entender é lá
na frente vai sorrir
o casal então nas ruas a ilusão que vão
sendo que se perde por andar na
contramão quem ele era fosse bem na sua
peça baiana que benção só uma ação west
uma miséria de cinco anos o myspace 7%
meu espírito santo e mato meu ego
pensava na caxa taxado de louco louco é
diferente nesse manicômio ea mudança
fred que só vota o amor deve deixar
melhor ópera ou seja a copa sob nosso
algum efeito borboleta é justo diz que
não sai da sua mas que vem também não
sei pra quê e pensei só não pode ser rei
as profundidades guardei a sabedoria
política sombra piqué que assombra
ouviam na praça de euros a esperança na
fila que possui
quem não está sujeita a ser tudo
funcionário bancos botafogo só se para
receber cinco chances são maiores que
envolvem league nessa linha passo lhe
valeu como a viajar esperança e
apreendidos onde responde se pede perdão
a banda mistura janelas o futuro de
jesus volta dia tudo vai mudar nós e eu
sei
organizações que expiram xira são fortes
emoções vai deixar o partido a deus numa
sala a intenção revelada quarta 1 a 0 do
flamengo sobre a oposição acostumado em
processo de apelação é assunto meu não
deu só sorrisos e novos negócios e
precisos aqueles que vão perceber que
não exista time todo faça e prove que o
artista
mesmo assim do ir das buscas desde o
passo a passo do futuro é incerto
deixe eu só posso perder a virgindade
mas nunca é 100 certo mg vitória es mas
pelas chances que vem conversando se
chocado com a dor apenas a provocar essa
situação queria nem seja opcional
aperfeiçoam mais uma vez em 61 acham
achei a latam e não sei lá com os amigos
da estação será o dia suja as mãos
o dia não vai lugar você eu sei se
jogarei homem é o prefeito ar só quero
que fique bem a noite foi longa e
girando mais lugar eu a você eu sei isso
a lei ao homem à senhora que lá só quero
sentir bem
e quem votado com essa frase cálculo
efeito borboleta é a juventude que não
sabe o caso
meu caro na cama que frase é essa mulher
e fui ver o tal do filme efeito
borboleta
eu sabia que existe um filme né mas não
tem nada a ver essa música como teoria
da conspiração
eu fui ver o filme porque realmente eu
tinha escrito isso e tudo que tudo que é
o filme abordará a filosofia de vida do
filho da filosofia do filme tinha a ver
com as coisas que estava escrevendo
baseado na minha experiência e não nomes
da música vai ser feito borboleta e
ficou ea galera começou a ouvir meu som
das músicas e falava que estava gostando
deus não tenho uma responsabilidade
escrever só mexendo com as pessoas com
as aulas estão a responsabilidade maior
e começou a gerar um amor muito grande
em mim pra escrever e compor o que me
deixou mais intrigado que dentro dessa
música tá escrito assim estou focada em
relógio parado para desilusões momento
e lá em casa tem um relógio parado só
que eu nunca tinha percebido que no
fundo do relógio tem um monte de
borboleta
então cara é esse é o caminho
o nacionalizando te dizendo que o prêmio
e como se inscrever só que agora mais
compulsivo meu quarto cheio de frases
para todo lado do laboratório costumo
dizer que o acesso bomba caseira e certo
dia estava em casa e continua escrevendo
escrevendo e várias reflexão e agente do
hip hop eu particularmente também a
gente costuma buscar referência em
livros antigos coisas antigas e eu
estava lendo um livro do grande escritor
que eu admiro a dos rankings lê o nome
do livro admirável mundo novo
e ele fala exatamente o que está
acontecendo nos dias de hoje a frieza
dos seres humanos o comportamento
agressivo por causa da tecnologia de uma
série de coisas que estavam acontecendo
no mundo e pra quem sabe se virar uma
salada coquetel molotov para quem
escritor pai eu fiquei irado pouca tudo
que estou escrevendo cara também tava
falando pô mas eu sempre fui motivado
pelo amor por pelo que saiu de dentro de
mim para fazer algo nunca foi uma
vaidade usar o talento para isso não
eu queria usar o talento para mostrar
aquilo que eu tinha dentro de mim é
porque de fato fazia sentido na vida das
pessoas na sociedade moderna
ainda mais que os valores invertidos né
era como um quebra-cabeça de ponta
cabeça
onde a gente tentar ouvir com as cores e
tentar colocar no lugar e inspirado
nesse livro doado os rankings lei
eu escrevi essa frase somos maduros
alienados
viramos bebês em frascos ea felicidade
tende a seguradora não existe tristeza
nessa incubadora dessa fonte também
quero beber mas o que esperar de quem só
quer receber e consequentemente saiu
logo da música o kit move e eu vou
cantar ela agora também
o o hospital aberto à sociedade ou
reposição seleciona com paixão e emoção
surgiu a propósito isso vai realizar
cirurgia pela internet significa esse
mercado que ainda tinha esta solução
aprimorado no chão quando querem matar o
governo fez quando achou uma multidão já
os problemas com pessoas não são
sentidas em campo apenas com os recursos
realidade era ótimo disco surgiu da
amizade retomada que se vê por essa
gente pede pelo seu onze povo quer a sua
vida com isso ensina provocar a zon
avança o problema foi pela saco preside
a festa chega o calor defesa dominou
noites a beija-flor escola porque no
futebol o que importa mesmo morta por
dentro e de fora do fórum de moda
portuguesa e sport por fora o que move
por dentro de moda fora são os votos
alinhados às vezes clássicos ea
felicidade que a seguradora não existe
tristeza nessa incubadora
essa ponte também quer ver que só quer
receber a turma de unha ou já ouviu
falar na linguagem evitar os motivos
rendimento na escrita não faz parte da
agenda da semana das estrelas do mercado
seguida o objetivo da questão legal
anatel que não sabia do cro um legado é
de borracha paga e legítimo não marcado
olhando à frente do 8 comum um livro de
óbito não vou ser mais um a deixar como
já dito disse dando à frente do suíço
com um livro de história no bolso mais
um com seus problemas e volte demonstrou
estar contrariar aquilo que eu disse que
ela cria um gênio da região cheio é
muito cobiçado por santos ferreira
só que agora em conseqüentemente
desertores posso dizer com clareza do
papel cuja estrutura se era pra ser
lenta e uma queda nas ruas 7,1 quilos é
absurda a reagir com pontes na madruga
menino que eles aluno fica na chave o
detran mostra o egito e gaza pai delacy
o outro de ajuda aos pequenos romeu o
teu e pec que ela pôs meu iphone ia para
seu vizinho o mundo padece carece
carinho que move podendo deste modo
forte que move por dentro de moda do
pólo de moda por ter que te move por
fora e por dentro de moda por fora
e é isso aí galera que eu tinha para
compartilhar pra vocês mas eu quero
deixar duas perguntas o kit move e você
já saiu do caso
muito boa noite a todos meu nome é
rodrigo no nome artístico aspecto